Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to find out what happens when
several AI agents play a video game together. So,
in particular, what happens if we put
25 of these amazing ChatGPT AI agents,
give them motivations and memory, and put them
in a simulated town? The answer is magic. Magic
happens. What I mean by that is that interesting
social behaviors emerge. They plan their days,
form relationships, invite each other to
parties, they love to talk and talk and talk,
I wonder what these discussions are about?
Yes, of course, I am going to tell you soon.
Initially, we find them asleep, and then they
wake up and start their morning routine. They
brush their teeth, get in the shower, and
dress up. Or, like good Fellow Scholars,
they want to read papers, or get this, to work on
their own papers. Yes, really! That’s how we know
that this is a good, Scholarly game. But all this
is not surprising. The surprising part starts now.
Remember, they are ChatGPT agents, so yes,
they converse in full natural language. Here
is an example conversation. John asks Tom
”Hey, have you heard anything new about the
upcoming mayoral election?” Then Tom answers,
“No, not really. Do you know who is running?”
Yes, there really is an election going on in
this little simulated town. How cool is that?
For instance, later Isabella says to
Tom: “I’m still weighing my options,
but I’ve been discussing the election with Sam
Moore. What are your thoughts on him?” Where Tom,
a separate ChatGPT agent says “To be honest,
I don’t like Sam Moore. I think he’s out of
touch with the community and doesn’t
have our best interests at heart.”
Wow. They ask each other’s opinions, and try
to be informed citizens for the elections.
Really cool. So what is the result? The
result is that the life these agents live
resemble the interactions of real humans.
Okay, but how much do they resemble real
humans? That will be a huge surprise, I
will tell you by the end of this video.
What I also loved is that these agents also
engage in self-reflection. They think, who am
I and what is important for me? For instance,
you see here how one of the agents, Klaus,
reflects on his observations, and finds out that
he is highly dedicated to doing research. A Fellow
Scholar at heart I see. Excellent! Like it is
true for us humans too, reflection is important.
Sometimes we have to look back, reflect and
learn some new lessons based on our experiences.
Thus, these agents can also be asked what they are
the most excited about, they check their memories,
and Isabella finds out that she is most
excited about throwing a Valentine’s Day Party.
And that is one of the most interesting parts of
the paper, because of two reasons. Question 1,
is how did this party come about, and question 2,
did the party really happen? The party came about
because one of the scientists specified to the
character that it wants to throw a Valentine’s
Day party. The AI heard this as its own inner
voice, very cool, and tried to act on it. But
here comes question 2. Does the party happen, and
if so, how? Organizing this is not easy at all,
not even in a small simulated game. You see, lots
of things have to happen for this to take place:
all of the characters have to know about
the party, and they also have to show up.
But she really wants this party to happen, so
she tells our resident Fellow Scholar, Klaus,
who then fortunately tells Abigail about
it, and look at that! Isabella hears back
about the party from someone she didn’t
even invite yet. Information is flowing
in this little city like it would in a
real city among real humans. I love it.
Quoting the paper, “the agents autonomously spread
invitations to the party over the next two days,
make new acquaintances, ask each
other out on dates to the party,
and coordinate to show up for the party together
at the right time.” Wow. And the answer is yes,
the party indeed happened. Good job, little AIs!
And there is one more thing that
I would love to show you about
this paper. So here is where I fell off
the chair. Look. What? Are you kidding,
or is this real? Scientists at Google also asked
a bunch of humans to play the game, here they are,
and then they asked a separate set of evaluators
who found the AIs behavior more humanlike than the
humans themselves. Yes, they are more human than
humans. According to evaluators. Wow. Of course,
every test like this has its limits, and
note that this is just a simple game,
with simple interactions, not real life.
But this still keeps me up at night.
Some agents accepted the party
invitation, and some didn’t. And
this decision came back to them reflecting
back on who they are, what their goals are,
what their schedule is. This very much sounds like
human behavior. They have their own little lives,
and their own preferences. Little virtual friends.
Really cool experiment. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!